burkina faso y Mali pronto se unirán en
una federación al menos Esa es la
propuesta del Primer Ministro de burkina
faso de visita en bamaco esta semana
podemos formar una federación flexible
que vaya viento en popa y respete las
aspiraciones de los demás en casa un
proyecto para unir a dos países que son
similares burkina faso y Mali se
enfrentan a la violencia yihadista y
están dirigidos por gobiernos de
transición surgidos de un golpe militar
ambos también han exigido recientemente
la salida de los soldados franceses de
sus territorios Mali se acerca a Rusia y
en particular al grupo paramilitar
Wagner acusado de abusos regularmente
por parte de Occidente
son estamos dispuestos a compartir
nuestra experiencia nuestras ideas y
enriquecernos con las ideas y
experiencias de los demás especialmente
de nuestros hermanos con los que tenemos
el mismo objetivo
un objetivo común con tener la espiral
de violencia que apareció en Mali hace
una década que desde entonces se ha
extendido Más allá de sus fronteras en
la región del zagel una federación ya se
formó en 1959 entre Mali senegal y Sudán
se disolvió un año después en el momento
de la independencia